what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation I am going to do a first time watching
for the Disney animated film Princess and
the Frog I don't even know if I've seen a
trailer for this movie wow that's rare anyway
guys uh this is the last movie I am shooting
a reaction for the put up for a while I'm
out of town getting hitched and of course
Coy and John will be there it'd be weird if
they weren't they're more important than the
misses so that's such a dog if she's watching
don't know that's not a joke anyway we're
gonna be uh watching this leave a like that
would mean the world I love that if you could
do it I'm just loading this on Disney plus
and if you want to do a full interaction watch
along with me on whatever copy you can get
your hands out of the full Thrasher watches
logs are available for super sexual rejects
that are patreon and we cover a bunch of stuff
over there as well exclusively with reaction
highlights and watch along is included and
we are good to go let's see what this movie
is all about
[Music]
was this the I think the thing I heard was
this is the last hand-drawn animated movie
from Disney and they said this doesn't make
enough money oh please dear princess only
a kiss from you can break this terrible spell
that was inflicted on me by a wicked witch
classic the beautiful princess picked up the
slippery creature leaned forward raised him
to her lips kiss that little frog
I know it's a frog it's kind of gross it's
transformed into a handsome prince they were
married and lived happily ever after yeah
gotta go knocking on some frogs
do you ever I mean never kiss a frog
you are being abusive to the cat [Music] I
will do it kids are from these little white
girl's crazy [Music]
adorable you could whip something up like
that is that John Goodman's voice
hmm this is the best combo I've ever tasted
come here
oh but look at the communal experience about
good food it brings folks together from all
walks of life ain't that the truth and when
I opened up my home restaurant I tell you
people are gonna line up for miles around
just to get a taste of my food our food our
food Tiana's place you make a wish on the
evening star
that old star can only take you parted away
you gotta help along with some hard work of
your own and the law of action thought feeling
action just promise your daddy one thing that
you'll never ever lose sight of what's really
important okay money you focus on money
[Music]
I do miss good old-fashioned hand-drawn animation
well miss Tiana rough night for tips but
don't you worry Daddy we'll be there soon
oh that's that's sad it's touching
I'm enjoying these Tunes [Music] New Orleans
still like this [Music]
wow they got a real magic oh my God
[Music] well hello handsome dreams do come
true [Music] wow not interested at all at
least marry him for his money we're all going
out dancing tonight
besides you need napkins sweetheart
if I do a winning the Kentucky
I was totally making a joke about her focusing
on making money I didn't think the movie would
actually be about is that about it invited
the prince to a masquerade and he's staying
in our house is my personal guess wow that's
a big deal my mama always said the quickest
way to a man's heart is through his stomach
amen sister I'ma need about 500 of your man
kitchen Beignets for my ball tonight this
might cover it this should cover it just fine
I'm getting my restaurant the odds look at
it Mama doesn't it just make you Wanna Cry
and some yeah that's all I want for you sweetheart
to meet your prince charming and dance off
and do your happily ever after huh I don't
have time for dancing just gonna have to wait
a while but you've got time for singing I
know exactly where I'm going I'm getting closer
and closer every day wow [Music] whoa cool
[Music] nah man you're almost there get your
goals done overcome those obstacles [Music]
that's right you persevere this this is delightful
[Music] I
love this animation [Music] you are kind of
losing side of relationships and connections
as you're growing up
[Music] oh I was there this is why catchy
ass song damn Tiana girls actually is a very
relatable plotline we've all wanted to open
our own restaurant right I buy everyone here
a drink you have two choices
for reals gentlemen or something how y'all
doing oh my God whose voice is that I have
a wager I'm in the company I have a visiting
royalty it's pretty obvious it's remarkable
gentleman has just read my poem this chap
is obviously a charlatan you're in my world
now not your world I got friends on the other
side the other side of what
that's a nickel gentlemen just a little something
we have here in Louisiana a little politics
[Music] if you relax it will enable me to
do without anything at least God this music's
amazing the cards will tell the past the present
and the future as well just take three take
a little trip into your future with me what's
the harm in just taking a look you come from
two long lives
I'm a royal myself or my mother
it's the greenest the green is the green you
need and when I looked into your future it's
the green that I see I see your future the
you I see is exactly the man you always wanted
to be the one in charge
oh my God
what is going on [Music] [Applause] [Music]
[Applause] [Music]
that's some cool Voodoo [__] oh is he
like is he turning him into a frog and they're
doing like a reversal thingy just an educated
guess based off the fact they haven't brought
the Frog around it's getting be so late there's
still a few straggles
please please please you can't just wish on
a star and expect things
[Music] did not turn into a frog
[Music] wow look at that classic Disney gonna
be the house you'll see once I sign those
papers y'all Brock yes about that oh what
did you next do what by who came in offered
the full amount in cash oh my God little woman
of your background would have had a hands
full trying to run a big business like oh
man now hold on there you come come back
oh that's painful what happened
rich white family isn't racist I was starting
to think that Wishing on Stars was just for
babies and crazy people oh aren't you justice
pretty as a magnolia in May back into The
Fray good luck oh poor Tiana that's a real
bummer believe I'm doing this
you gotta put it in action but pushing to
the universe never bad thing I reckon you
want a kiss ing would be nice yeah wow
have a very strong iron princess oh he did
get turned into a frog it's him I am Prince
Naveen
must kiss me if excuse me you will enjoy I
guarantee all women enjoy the keys of Prince
Naveen come we pack her oh God no no surely
I could offer you some type of reward a wish
I could Grant perhaps oh don't just no just
one kiss the kiss has to go to true love and
let you beg for more oh God you're one disgusting
perverted frog
oh what happened but how'd you get way up
there and how did I get way down here and
all this oh oh my God [Music] that is not
slime what you are secreting mucus oh Tiana
[Music] just talked to me yeah yeah what I
can't get through with this [Music] why would
you want to look that way you wear this this
Costless thing anything happens to this I'm
gonna be fun fact about Voodoo Larry can't
conjure a thing for myself oh interesting
is that true is that part of the rules all
you got to do is marry Big Daddy's Little
Princess and we will be splitting that juicy
Libra Fortune right down ah I'm not a princess
I'm a waitress you weren't wearing a crown
it was a costume party you spoiled little
rich boy oh yes well the egg is on your face
all right because I do not have any riches
oh my God literally broke never heard anyone
say it was such Pride I want you two are married
you are gonna keep your promise and get me
my rest I made that promise to a beautiful
princess not the cranky wit why are those
logs moving
those aren't locks wow they're all gonna fight
for these two frogs
help me get out of this ah they go right back
to moving slow and hunt you can hop looks
like we're going to be here for a while we
may as well get confidence sleaze back God
damn it I got a little less Piggy
play it brother
[Music] [Applause]
[Applause] Mama Odie she the voodoo queen
of the Bayou she got magic and spells all
kind of who do that would actually come in
handyman [Music] so hot and strong like no
one they've ever seen parts of this cat arriving
here Jungle Book [Music]
she's an independent hard-working girl it's
funny how us humans are so bad at achieving
what these reptiles want to achieve you had
to endure that I'll be asked when you're next
in line for the throne you're poised like
a panther ready to expect [Laughter]
your ear
I can no longer ignore the throbbing of my
yikes it got me blushes
becoming princess of meldonia are you serious
that's the plague what do we do now I'm reduced
to asking for Help from My Friends on the
other side
what oh no there is no way I'm kissing a frog
and eating a bug on the same day I mean you
got turned into a frog You Gotta Throw That
Into The Mix
oh oh oh
you don't find anything to eat yeah oh my
I know miles that's raunchy
let me tell you something girl I guess you
and your boyfriend gonna look good I love
all the Louisiana personalities are infused
into all the animal characters
guts from the stomach Mama Woody y'all had
the wrong direction
[Music]
around stick I was confused by the topography
and the the geography and the choreography
and first rule to buy you never take direction
from a gator
oh wow
[Music] this movie is cute
I Love Actually as a walker seems our little
froggy prince lost his way and I need your
generous assistance getting them back
I hear you dude these souls are going to consume
me by the end of the movie
I do love the horror elements of the drawings
because it does remind me of like classic
Disney that's Supernatural peril
I can taste him frog legs already
[Music] oh they should be able to hear them
no wait no
that's it
what
get that little one over there
ouch
[Music]
dude this this guy's gonna have a concussion
watch this
[Music] oh these are some clever ass frogs
they're even using dance in a way these two
ain't like no frogs I ever seen and we talked
too [Applause] I'm a little confused now that
they're frogs they can hear all the other
animals but none of these other like bugs
and alligators like humans can't hear them
right I'll start with a pre-dinner cocktail
and something to nibble on but I wait you
are gonna mince these mushrooms do do what
you're gonna learn to do some labor with your
hands you spoiled frog
what
there you go when you live in a castle everything
is done for you dress you they feed you drive
you brush your teeth wipe your butt [Music]
spooky it's like a Leica movie
[Music] it's the star look how she lights
up the sky she [Music]
could love someone like me oh no I I don't
dance frog you will dance away I've never
danced never all this time in my life
is wonderful Love is Everything oh that's
delightful [Music]
damn
we best be pushing all right oh she she wanted
to kiss her if she wanted it I feel like she's
learning looks don't matter
[Music]
not bad for a 197 year old Blind Lady oh I'm
going to love her come on over here you bad
boy get a little sugar now oh no we don't
want to take up too much of your time I want
some candy no no thank you and now that's
too bad it's a special candy what a twin y'all
human oh we need to be human y'all ain't got
to say she was born with y'all want to be
human but you're blind to what you need what
we want what we need is all the same thing
yeah no no not at all don't matter what you
look like don't matter what you wear come
in the rain you got on your finger we don't
care no we don't oh this is gonna be a good
one I like this already [Music] oh it's a
good song
[Music] that's not what you need [Music]
can often feel that way the ironic part is
it costs a lot of money to put this movie
together
[Music]
oh he knows what he wants he needs love [Music]
oh this this one is a good number this one
on the um almost there fantastic I need to
dig a little deeper and work even harder to
get my restaurant no that's not it princess
but only till midnight you only got till then
to get that prices to kiss you what she does
I think you guys just gotta kiss each other
[Music]
no they're just instruments oh that is one
killer dealer costume hey Gator can you blow
that horn
oh this is the perfect party boat I just looked
Tiana in the eye and say and we'll do whatever
it takes to make all your dreams come true
because I love you whoa I'm in love with Tiana
knew it I knew it I knew it'd be so happy
I would find another way to get the other
restaurant the job practically guys no no
you are not a guy let me begin again oh you
are a bumbling fool when you're in love Tiana
there it is your restaurant oh can't you just
picture you know a good ukulele player really
you let me perform I'll talk to the owner
owner says yes
with your help our dream is finally coming
true oh damn it was gonna end what do I do
God damn it
Lawrence oh no hold still your eminence have
you seen Naveen look at you where the ring
at oh no don't give it away because oh wait
you're up tired of the drum you ain't getting
nothing out of me no Ray okay Charlotte he
go marry you as soon as he get himself kisses
oh I just light it up and here I thought
no no no you're misunderstanding this whole
situation just because you wish for something
doesn't make it true my vageline always said
to me if Angeline's nothing but just open
your eyes now don't revert back to who you
were at the beginning of the movie
are the power of this
I Now Pronounce You whoa
what's he doing I got it you got me too
it's interesting like the main villain is
his embodiment of what greed can do to you
the pursuit of money how can corrupt your
soul again I'm moving made by the richest
company in the world but I couldn't good message
what is this
shadow man get this no matter what no wrong
girl don't make me light my butt you light
your ass Ray [Music] know me come here
[Music]
did they really just squish him to death oh
I'm gonna break this thing into a million
pieces
oh my goodness
oh
the ultimate Temptation that was one hard-working
man shame all that hard work didn't amount
to much more than a busted up old Gumbo Pot
and a dream that never got off the back porch
but he always understood What mattered most
you can give your poor daddy everything he
ever wanted no no no he already had everything
he wanted that's why he worked so hard my
daddy never did get what he wanted but he
had what he needed
but he had what he needed yeah girl he never
lost sign what was
and neither will I
[Music]
getting what you want versus what you need
I like that I like that theme a lot it's not
slime it's mucus [Music] with your soul
[Music]
you had a car he had it coming oh Hello darling
to introduce myself I am the real Prince Naveen
if I kissed you before midnight you and Tiana
turn human again yeah more or less but remember
you must give Tian all the money she requires
for her restaurant she is my Evangeline
don't do this I have to do this and we are
running out of time I won't let you it's the
only way to get to your dream my dream my
dream wouldn't be complete what are you in
it
that's sweet too oh do you I read about true
love and fairy tales and you found it I'll
kiss him no marriage required [Music] oh
I'm so sorry
I wish you wiped off all the lipstick shadow
man to lay Paul Ray low hey he's hurting awful
bad oh poor Ray how'd he survive that how
come yo
and we're staying together we're staying frogs
right I locked down very much
Evangeline are you managers in his eyes [Music]
oh really this is so unexpected poor Ray foreign
gets to be with Evangeline though
[Music] yay he gets to be with Evangeline
but now she'll frog
[Music]
frog
it's my good looking couple like I told y'all
he's an apprentice
that made you a princess it makes a lot of
sense it's real logical that's extremely logical
conclusion [Music] this is an inspiring independent
woman
they should create a Tiana's Palace would
have had a younger brother how old did you
say you were I'm six and a half just wait
a few years
[Music] did they ever create like a Tiana's
Palace somewhere I'm going to New Orleans
baby
that was really cute really really cute oh
all righty another Disney animated movie crossed
off the good old Greg list here and uh I enjoyed
it I thought it was a really cute light-hearted
Disney Flair I mean one of the best parts
about it is the fact that it's hand-drawn
animation you know just there's a certain
kind of movement and uh that's pastel elasticity
to the the movement and the expressions and
body movement that you don't quite get I mean
sometimes the the computer animation in some
of these movies is phenomenal they're gonna
be Rochester with the human movements they've
they've certainly um vastly evolved since
like this movie came out I think in 2009 and
since then if we've gotten like so much more
mind-blowing like I just watched Moana recently
that was like mind-blowing and I I really
think that you know that's part of the the
touch that I missed was that was that was
that frame to frame movement you know and
uh I I think that was excellent and and so
nostalgic in it of itself just having the
hand-drawn quality to it and uh I like them
the messages and and themes overall you know
it's kind of a the similar type of message
that some of the live-action remakes of like
Mary Poppins returns or the the sequel the
Christopher Robin movie oh this is our remakes
like like remake sequel thingies whatever
the weird live action films of of uh not getting
so caught up in a rat race and there's more
to life than monetary gain and trying to make
money uh that really you should learn to be
uh value and appreciate the things in life
that that you truly you know I truly matter
the connections the love the memories that
you generate over time those things like I
love how they broke it down from you know
there are things that you want and then there
are things that you need isn't there a song
like that you can't always get what you want
but you get what you need is that how the
song goes um and so I really love that message
overall because that is any message like that
I always think of you know being grateful
for what you have in life and realizing that's
the little things in life that are the most
important is a is a constant daily reminder
you know like I didn't grow up with money
and you know constantly just working many
hours and like many of the people I know many
of the friends that I have it it's and especially
being out in La you know I don't know it's
like in New Orleans it seems like it's kind
of around the world it's a societal thing
like the the emphasis on the hustle the emphasis
on making money and how that seems to equate
to some type of value of a human being I I
can I think so many of us can can relate to
that of we often get blinded by the chase
of the external goals in life and while I
think like no there is like there's an importance
to that like she ends up getting her the Tiana's
Palace in the end for a reason it's not like
she goes I don't need this you know I just
want love the thing is in pursuit of that
of of of achieving that goal you you don't
want to lose sight of the things that really
do matter which are the experiences and connections
with the people we we love you know I I do
imagine of the the that that feeling of if
I'm when I'm on my deathbed am I going to
be thinking about you know the getting those
views of on the channel and oh and those views
were great or um you know the the the the
money successes I've noticed like any time
I've I'm always like even even in this line
of work you know sometimes I could put like
a lot of time and editing into a certain video
and then it could do really well and like
that could feel like the most important thing
in the world to me in that time but then once
I achieve it or does really well or sometimes
even you know get go trending or something
that doesn't feel quite I'm always appreciative
I don't want that to misconstrue it doesn't
feel quite as rewarding as you sort of fantasize
it will be you know and it's kind of been
like that for almost every aspect of my life
that ever involves some type of career-based
or job-based type of thing you know uh and
it's it's so easy to like compare yourself
to others or look at what others have and
I I love I love being reminded of that message
and watching sports especially through the
through the perspective of a woman yeah I
feel like we don't really get that that often
It's usually the the guy even those two live-action
Disney movies I mentioned those are men who
are dealing with that obstacle in their life
of not being attentive to their families and
but if it's the man so I I and I I really
really liked how we got it from a woman's
perspective and I like the Tiana character
I really like the portrayal and there was
something that felt refreshing about it studied
in New Orleans with the jazz songs and and
uh and just the plot of how it unfolded like
doing a little bit of a fliparoo when they
both become frogs and there's also you know
some messages there uh that they don't overtly
speak at least unless I missed it but they
don't quite as overtly talk on it maybe more
with the uh Prince Naveen character who is
a lost soul in the time as well but the the
concept of you know not not everything's about
looks as well you know like she's even like
I would never kiss a frog so they really do
find true love internally for who they are
uh uh underneath the physicality who they
are as Souls which is quite beautiful as well
and I love the the songs too like there are
two in there that really stood out to me um
I believe one has to be called almost there
one of the earlier songs and then the one
with hold on I got I did pull up IMDb on here
it was Keith David hell yeah I got that right
oh [__] that was Oprah did not know Terence
Howard that voice was very familiar anyway
that's getting caught up now and just getting
the names down it what was the the lady in
the in the swamp uh Mama Odie played by Jennifer
Lewis um yeah Mama Odie her uh her song number
was also really awesome and I love that one
too yeah there were parts of the animation
that kind of reminded me of Hercules that
kind of remind me of um even parts of like
The Rescuers Down Under and Jungle Book so
I I really thought that was that was awesome
so yeah messages themes the everything was
just like really light-hearted fair that I
that I thought was really enjoyable I wouldn't
say I quite loved the movie and I think that
was because I wasn't quite in love with the
characters like I didn't I liked them all
I liked everyone here like literally everyone
I I really liked if anyone I came close to
loving if it's Tiana um but I but yeah I wasn't
as hyper invested in in the characters as
as I would probably be your like usually with
these movies it doesn't even need to be at
all I mean it usually just needs to be like
just that one who I'm just like really drawn
to uh but I don't know there was I'm not sure
what was quite missing for it from me there's
something within the the writing itself that
sort of like I like I said I don't want it
to to sound like I don't like the movie because
I actually do it I didn't like it I would
just say it I don't like the movie but I I
just it wasn't quite as um yeah I guess there
was a missing piece of something there that
felt like there was some type of Gravitas
that doesn't need to be like the deepest thing
in the world but there was a bit of an emotional
weight that wasn't just quite clicking for
me that I I did I sort of craved a little
bit more of because you know the day it's
like a breezy lightheart Affair and the movie's
made for kids and I think it excels in that
area and I think it's a family movie with
a lot of great things on its mind and also
with the expressive Exquisite animation and
uh it's still solid voice performances I I
I still give it like a really solid recommendation
but yeah you know uh I I I think it's a just
think it's a it's just a fun light cute movie
you can see that I know that John has seen
this movie before and uh he he says one of
his favorites and and uh my now wife Olivia
is she at the another time filming this but
after she she really loves this movie too
and for me I'm I'm not sure there was something
there that just quite wasn't I know because
I don't I didn't want to like sit back here
and like over analyze it so I'm trying to
sort of figure out in the moment of talking
with you guys of what was it about this movie
that just didn't quite make me fall in love
with it and I guess yeah there was just something
about the characters in and of itself that
was
there were parts of it that it's not even
the word flat that's a problem sometimes when
you do these movie reactions and you're talking
off the Flyers you got it sort of figured
out in the moment
yeah I guess I just felt like I needed something
that felt a a little bit of an extra umph
in the because it because yeah you know what
it might be it's not so much the the it like
I think Tiana like individually is a wonderful
character it's more of the way the relationships
and connections form over time like even with
them falling in love it was like oh I guess
they hit that beat but the way they got there
I didn't feel like I was there with them on
the on the journey to falling in love like
oh they've fallen in love but I I didn't uh
I didn't feel though the the the the the the
the transition to there that strong and then
the other characters were kind of like two-dimensional
they all had they're all like fun quirky but
I think like what really needed to sing like
massively for me was the connection with um
Prince Naveen and and uh and um my God sorry
for saving and uh Tiana like that was the
part of it that I thought really needed to
really hit for me and that part I didn't quite
fall even though I was happy for them in the
end and I really like the adorableness of
it yeah I guess my review was me explaining
why I liked it and really enjoyed it a lot
but didn't quite reach the I love its level
which can sometimes when you're on the internet
sound like you don't actually like the movie
when that is not the case and so I felt the
need to really try to explain my way there
but really the the answer is I I just really
liked it a lot but I didn't quite I didn't
I didn't fall in love with it that's that's
just the bottom line I don't I don't know
why I feel like I had to really try to explain
it so much um but yeah I still thought those
songs were great I think there's so still
so much to appreciate and and I am really
grateful that I gotta watch this movie finally
it's been on my list for like this whole year
so I'm glad I finally got to watch it and
I feel like I'd still revisit a couple like
I watched Moana recently and I found myself
like listening to a couple of the songs when
I'm like at the gym and I feel like I put
on a couple of these songs as well or even
just watch the videos themselves because of
the animation for that really really sing
loudly for me but yeah guys Princess and the
Frog is it one of your favorites do you love
the hell out of it leave your thoughts down
below be sure to subscribe click that Bell
leave a like and uh hey let's send this with
a
mark Leach mark I want you to know buddy that
if you were a frog I would kiss you I'd make
out with you Mark I just lick you all over
I get all that mucus all over me I would hope
to God that if you were a frog you would choose
me to be the one you want to be kissed by
because Mark I love you I think you're an
amazing guy I think you're a talented dude
and you are someone who from the things you've
told me about the interactions that you have
you sound like you you're probably an effective
influential inspiring person to a lot of people
who are very important in your life I really
mean that part I mean I'm sure I mean the
part too if if you were a frog I guess you
sure I mean that too but I mean the other
more sincere things the serious things that
we've talked about I really wouldn't take
for granted the experiences you told me about
and what you actually do for a lot of the
people around you you sound like someone who's
very much treasured and valued and I don't
think you give yourself enough credit for
that so please know that just from what I've
gone to know from about you that you seem
like a insanely insanely just influential
individual you're the real influence around
her he's like a real influential person and
one of positivity even darkest times so thank
you for being in our lives and I hope 2023
after all the [__] that you got dealt
with in 2022 I hope 2023 ends up being a a
much bigger rebound of a year they often say
in life you know You're Going Through Hell
keep going and I believe one of the keys to
Life's experiences is to experience so sometimes
you got to experience some real darkness in
order to experience some real joy and you've
had some Darkness to deal with this year so
I hope in 2023 you're able to just have a
very joyous time love you buddy hope you're
doing well